forza horizon 3 has gone gold and we
just learned a bunch of new information
about both the pc and xbox one versions
of the game I'm Tony and this is your
speedy gamespot news update first off
halos warthog will be among the game's
350 plus vehicles the warthog previously
appeared as an easter egg in forts of 4
but this is the first time it'll be
playable it's modeled after the civilian
version of the Halo series famous
military truck additionally microsoft
revealed the full list of achievements
for the Xbox one version of the game as
well as the recommended specs for the pc
version you can head over to gamespot to
browse both lists forza horizon 3 is
coming to xbox one and pc on sep tember
27th buying the hundred-dollar ultimate
edition gets you in four days early
horizon 3 is part of the play anywhere
lineup so buying the digital version of
the game on one platform gets you the
game on the other to keep up with all
the forts and news you're already in the
right place